Speaker 1: All right, this next story is a
very big deal.
The Jan. six Trump Riot Committee, the committee
investigating the Jan. six, 2021, Trump riots,
is quite frankly doing a very good job of
something that is very difficult.
There are so many different aspects to the
Trump riots.
What was Trump up to in the time leading up
to what was going on within law enforcement?
What were Trump's kids doing?
What were members of the House doing?
What were members of the Senate doing?
Who knew what, when, etc. records that need
to be obtained?
All these different things.
The last two weeks have generated new evidence
for the committee because Donald Trump's reaction
to the committee's actions now appear to be
witness tampering.
And in fact, Congressman Pete Aguilar said
on CNN yesterday Trump is tampering with witnesses,
which is again scaling up the criminality
potential of what Donald Trump has been up
to.
So we have a CNN report about this January
6th committee member says Trump absolutely
tampering with witnesses as he continues to
dangle pardons.
Let's take a look at this video clip here.
Speaker 4: That lawyer represents other Jan.
six defendants and said that Rhodes and others
would welcome a Trump pardon.
Is Trump tampering with witnesses when he's
talking about pardons, when he's dangling
them in front of one six defendants?
Speaker 3: Absolutely.
And I think the question is more for my colleagues
on the other side of the aisle, you know,
where where are they?
Do they support this?
When is enough enough?
When a mob is chanting, Hang Mike Pence?
It wasn't enough.
When the former president asked Brad Raffensperger
to find him 11000 votes frozen enough.
Right now, he's dangling a pardons if he gets
back in office for individuals.
Will that be enough or will there be more
collective amnesia?
You know, I just don't know where the floor
is these days on that.
Where is the
Speaker 1: floor and what is the bottom or
whatever it is that you want to describe it
and what's being referred to here.
And what's funny is this isn't even the first
time that Donald Trump is dangling pardons
in a way that could be seen as witness tampering.
Remember that back with during the Russia
probe, where you had Paul Manafort, Carter
Page, Roger Stone, all these different people
being investigated and interviewed, and many
subsequently charged for lying to the FBI
or different things.
Donald Trump did the exact same thing.
He talked about those who are staying strong.
And he talked in a circuitous sort of roundabout
way about the possibility of pardons.
It could have been argued at that point, and
many legal experts did argue that's a form
of witness tampering.
You were signaling to these individuals if
you don't cooperate.
I may pardon you in the future if you don't
cooperate.
There may be good things coming, and if you
do cooperate, you're going to be on the list
of bad boys, so to speak, and you're no longer
going to be in my good graces or whatever
the case may be.
Here, Donald Trump is doing a very similar
thing with the Trump rioters themselves.
It's different because there's a really good
chance Trump is never going to pardon any
of them.
And this is sort of like multistep.
It's not at all clear that Donald Trump will
be the Republican nominee in 2024.
If he is the Republican nominee, it's not
at all clear that Donald Trump will win the
presidential election in 2024 if Trump wins
the 2024 presidential presidential election,
there is no guarantee that he will actually
pardon any of these people.
And so not only is it another attempt to potentially
influence the behavior of the writers and
of those, and this is an important addition.
It's not only about influencing the behavior
of the writers themselves in their cases,
but also of Republicans, more so in the House,
but in theory in the House and Senate and
other people around Trump in general about
cooperation with the committee or the Trump
right.
It's a bigger signal.
But it's not even clear that Trump really
intends to follow through on this.
And you can.
You can make the argument, as Pete Aguilar
does on CNN, that it is a form of witness
tampering.
Now, the obvious question is, well, so should
we expect a criminal referral to the Department
of Justice?
And it is not because Donald Trump will go
to prison.
I maintain Trump is not going to prison.
But at what point do we say?
The facts just point to there should be a
criminal referral from the Jan. six committee
to the Department of Justice and then put
it on the Department of Justice to decide
we will or won't investigate, we will or won't
charge, put it on Merrick Garland to actually
sort of be pushed into having to do something
when it comes to this.
When is enough enough?
And consider with Hillary Clinton vis-a-vis
Benghazi.
Endless hearings, special investigation hearing
report all these different things.
Demanding charges demanding Hillary Clinton
be locked up.
Absent any charges.
Ignoring their stated principle of the value
of due process and constitutionality.
And the rule of law and law and order.
And all these things.
There wasn't even anything there and they
were saying Lock up Hillary Clinton.
It seems at minimum here there is more than
enough evidence and factual basis for a criminal
referral to the Department of Justice.
And then let's see how the Department of Justice
deals with it.
I don't expect this to stop, and we continue
to follow the now more than 700 cases 700
defendants in the Trump riots, now 13, almost
13 months to the day beyond that date.
The sentences are starting to come in and
we will see where it ends up, but without
a doubt, this is arguably another instance
of witness tampering.
And if you're Trump, if there were no repercussions
to the earlier witness tampering with the
Russia probe.
Why would you behave any differently now,
of course you wouldn't, and that's part of
this entire thing.
We'll have that clip of Congressman Pete Aguilar
on our Instagram.
You can find that at David Pakman show, we're
going to take a quick break.
And we've got a really interesting interview
coming up not about the one percent, but about
the nine point nine percent.
What does that mean?
It's a very interesting group, culturally
and economically.
And we're going to talk about that after this
short break.